we only use 10 of our brains so this is
not true the bigger the brain the
smarter the creature
size doesn't matter you can't prevent a
stroke
no that's not true that's very not true
actually hi i'm dr santoshi bilakota i'm
a clinical assistant professor in
neurology at the nyu grossman school of
medicine i'm dr brad kamitaki i'm a
neurologist and assistant professor at
rutgers robert wood johnson medical
school and today we'll be debunking
myths about the human brain the bigger
the brain the smarter the creature
size actually does not matter when it
comes to the brain because there are
creatures out there with bigger brains
than us but probably not as complex your
brain is really determined by your body
proportion right so when you think of
like a big brown bear that's way bigger
than us their brain is going to be
bigger but that doesn't necessarily mean
that they are smarter than us we don't
know that for sure because it hasn't
been fully studied but we've seen that
in instances such as chimpanzees they do
have smaller brains but we do know for a
fact that chimpanzees are probably as
smart as we are certainly it's not the
size of the brain that matters but
probably how complex it is and how well
developed certain areas are certain
areas in humans are for example our
language centers are just much more
developed than a cow or even a
chimpanzee yeah that's important in
determining intelligence rather than the
size itself and also how do we measure
intelligence that also becomes tricky
because not everyone is intelligent in
the same way non-cognitive factors also
play a role like what's your social
intelligence what's your emotional
intelligence all of that i think is very
complex and really difficult to measure
iq tests are always an accurate measure
of intelligence so
this is false there's so much that goes
into intelligence normal intelligence
tests might measure things like
executive function or planning verbal
skills reading skills things like that
but it's only an approximation of what
you can do and highly influenced by the
conditions of the test how you're
feeling at the time of the test your
educational level it'll be nice to say
that there's one test or one way that we
can determine how intelligent someone is
but there's so much that goes into
intelligence that one test or even
multiple different tests can't measure
that very well so the popular iq test
was developed in the early 1900s and it
was a way to determine which french
students were cognitively delayed so we
could offer them better resources that
got adopted in america at stanford where
for all the reasons brad laid out it
doesn't take all of those things into
account so i think although it is nice
to say hey i am smart i did well on an
iq test really don't think that means
too much neither of us were born being
doctors right we had to learn and
develop those skills under many years of
training i think that education is the
best way to kind of make that happen
education very broadly that might not
necessarily be school for everyone
definitely some people are savants some
people are prodigies it's really hard to
say what determines that they might be
better at certain things but not
necessarily good at others we're all
individuals we all have different
talents and different aptitudes for
different things so iq tests just kind
of measure your intelligence in that one
specific area not how overall
intelligent you are we only use 10 of
our brains so this is not true we
actually use all of our brain not all of
the time but most of the time we're
using some percentage of her brain this
myth came into fruition i think in the
early 1800s where people were trying to
figure out why injuring different parts
of the brain caused disabilities in
people so a bunch of psychologists came
up with the theory that we only use
about ten percent of our brains versus
people who are smarter who use more now
we simply know that that is not the case
we know that because we have something
called a pet mri and a functional mri
study we have the frontal lobe which we
use for a lot of different purposes
motor function language function
executive functioning or planning
activities behind that our parietal lobe
here which is our sensory cortex in the
back of the brain we have the occipital
lobe which is our visual processing
center and then here on the side we have
the temporal lobe which is involved in
memory language comprehension on the
left side so to give you an example if
you are reading something you're going
to be using your temporal lobes for
comprehension you're going to be using
your frontal lobes for comprehension
you'll also be using the back of your
head where your visual cortex sits
because that's where information from
your eyeballs travel and your body kind
of makes sense of it that way and then
also if we
take the brain apart a little bit we
have our brain stem over here which is
kind of our lizard brain it's our
primitive brain that controls things
like level of arousal breathing
respirations heart rate blood pressure
we have some deep motor functions here
in the brain as well another part of the
brain that we have is our cerebellum
kind of on the bottom which is also
involved in motor control and motor
planning in doing one task you could be
using multiple parts of your brain but
you're not using everything at the same
time video games rot your brain so this
is a myth video games in and of
themselves don't actually rot your brain
it's something that i definitely heard a
lot when i was younger from my grandma
my mom a lot of our literature has shown
that video games especially the ones
that focus on team building on solving
riddles solving puzzles building
strategy are actually pretty good for
you they actually do build up those
centers of your brain especially when
you're a child you know games can be
used for other purposes for example our
colleagues in surgery when they do
scopes they practice those skills with
things like video game simulators
looking at the trials no one has
actually defined what too much video
games is every literature study that
i've looked at quotes between 12 hours
to 90 hours a week is okay i feel like
90 hours might be a little excessive but
i think in reality the bigger signs of
someone withdrawing from social
activities and wanting to just stay at
home and play video games and they'd
prefer to do that then do other things
that's more of a red flag i always say
everything in moderation like if it's
affecting your social life if you're
just stuck in front of the tv all day
that's not good psychologically memory
gets worse as you age so this is false
in fact there are some types of memory
that improve as you get older for
example things like semantic memory your
vocabulary reading procedural memory for
example people that are very good at
musical instruments like can play the
piano often will retain those skills
some people will notice some changing
memory that's often things like episodic
memory which is kind of our memory of
recent events episodic memories
basically like the who what where and
when so where did i put my keys where
did i park my car those kind of things
do tend to decline and i think a lot of
it is because we just aren't as focused
on things it's not necessarily something
that's pathological or suggests dementia
not everyone will get dementia but that
risk does increase as you get older
right now we don't have any medications
or treatments that can prevent someone
from getting alzheimer's disease there
are some environmental risk factors that
if you address can prevent you from
getting dementia or at least prevent
your memory from getting worse so some
of those things include just general
health eating healthy foods taking care
of your heart moderate exercise making
sure that you stay healthy
cardiovascularly which is also going to
help your brain left brain people are
logical and right-brained people are
creative
i think this myth came from the 1800s
when as neurologists are trying to
figure out different functions of the
brain they discovered that the left side
of our brain and most people is dominant
for language verbal memory whereas the
right brain was much more of our visual
spatial functions but there's no
structural brain difference in people
who are more logical or versus more
creative rather it's more their
environment the way that they were
raised in neurology when we talk about
brain hemispheric dominance we typically
are talking about language and verbal
memory dominance where does that live
and for most people that's on the left
side of the brain so if you're
right-handed about 90 of the time you're
going to be left hemisphere dominant
which means a lot of your memory and
speech production and understanding
comprehension that kind of stuff is
going to sit on the left side of your
brain whereas if you're a left-handed it
can kind of go both ways so i think the
reality is we say that someone is left
brain dominant or right brain dominant
and it doesn't really mean that one
person is more creative and the other
one is more logical these are just
talents and sort of skills that people
develop whether inherently or through
their personalities but it really has
nothing to do with the side of their
brain that they use more you can't
prevent a stroke
no that's not true that's very not true
actually you can definitely prevent a
stroke how to do that is by really
addressing all the factors that could
result in a stroke we know very clearly
that things like high blood pressure
smoking high cholesterol diabetes
unfortunately increase your risk for a
stroke which is basically when there's
sign of blood flow going to your brain
because of a blood clot or bleeding in
the brain there's no quick and easy fix
again it's about maintaining your
cardiovascular and brain health over
time so that you never get into a
situation where a stroke will occur if
you do ever have symptoms of a stroke
and we often tell people this fast
mnemonic so facial droop arm weakness
slurred speech or language problems and
then t is time call 9-1-1 and get to the
hospital right away emergency medicine
physicians can give you plot-busting
medications to break up the clot that's
causing the stroke so there's things
that we can do to address it and prevent
it from getting worse and i think
there's a misconception that stroke is
an old person's disease we know this
isn't true anyone of any age can have a
stroke the reason why you're going to
have it is going to be different if
you're older versus when you're younger
but a big cause of stroke in young
people is brain bleeds if you have a
family history of aneurysm you should
definitely get screened i think that's
actually recommended eating fish makes
you smarter so i actually don't know
where this one came from but maybe it's
like an immigrant household thing but i
heard this a lot yeah yeah i mean in
asian households for sure this is tricky
because fish doesn't necessarily make
you smarter but it is good for you and
some fish more than others have omega-3s
which we know are good for heart health
good for brain health and just good for
your overall body health so i think
maybe that's why this one came into
place but i don't think it makes you
smarter what do you think yeah no i
think it was my parents way of getting
more efficient you do have to be careful
about eating too much fish we know that
certain types of fish have more mercury
than others like tuna you don't want to
overdo it i should add that fish is part
of a mediterranean diet which we
advocate for all of our patients
mediterranean diets are diets that are
rich in good fats like fish for example
olive oils vegetables healthy grains and
that is going to be helpful for stroke
prevention it's going to be good for
cholesterol for hypertension for
diabetes all kinds of stuff so fish as
part of a healthy diet is good for you
but it will not make you smarter you can
always trust your senses
i'd say that's a myth our senses can
play tricks on us and cause things like
illusions or even sometimes
hallucinations for example people with
schizophrenia might hear voices of
people talking that aren't actually
there our senses are not 100 objective
they're dependent on how well our brains
and you know eyes ears are functioning
at that time everyone is different my
pain tolerance might be lower than rats
or vice versa i don't think we have a
really good neurological way of
explaining why that might be that's
still something that we don't fully
understand also your senses can be
a little influenced by emotions and
memories i think if you see something
that reminds you of someone the way
you're going to react to it might be a
little different i don't know if what
i'm seeing is the same thing that
everyone else is seeing like how can we
ever it's like when they had that blue
dress and the black dress and people
were saying different things different
sexes have different brains
so no that's not true and i'm going to
rip it again because that was funny
i should start with saying that we're
all born with the same brain regardless
of what your gender identity is
regardless of what your sexual
orientation is there's really no
structural differences so if a
neurosurgeon was looking at two
different brains they wouldn't know who
was assigned male at birth and who was
assigned female at birth there have been
studies out there that have shown that
those have been assigned female at birth
might have more robust emotional
pathways versus those who've been
assigned male at birth are more
executive thinkers we now know that
that's not true as you get older if
you've been exposed to different things
how you relate to the outside world
that's what develops the structures of
your brain and the connectivity it has
really nothing to do with what gender
you were assigned at birth it's more
nurture it's not necessarily nature and
how you're made if you have a seizure
you have epilepsy no
i'm going to rip this a few times
because i want to make my point what a
seizure is is hypersynchronation of
brain cells so what is that your brain
talks to itself using electricity if
something goes wrong with electricity in
your brain you have a seizure basically
when all of your neurons freak out and
fire at once your body hyper
synchronizes and we have a seizure
seizures can be due to a lot of things
not necessarily epilepsy which is a
lifelong neurological condition you have
to have multiple unprovoked seizures and
that's the difference between a seizure
and epilepsy also if you have epilepsy
you have to take daily medication to
keep your brain from having seizures so
if you have had your first seizure of
lifetime or if you're someone with
seizures there are a few things that you
should do one definitely get checked out
by a neurologist there are tests that we
can order that can be helpful for you
one of them is an eeg we put stickers on
your head look at your brain waves and
see where the abnormalities are and the
second one is the imaging that we have
mris and pet mris are both used and if a
diagnosis of epilepsy is made the most
important thing for you to do is take
your medications and lastly keep
communicating with your doctor because
you're not going to get to that period
of seizure freedom unless you
communicate with your doctor you only
get one brain you're born with all the
brain cells that you are going to have
and it's up to you to take care of them
there's a grain of truth in a lot of
these myths but they're just not fully
accurate just make sure that you do your
research and take care of yourself